so when I was 19 years old I was a
pledge and my fraternity pledges had to
be Designated Drivers so I would drive
drunk Brothers home all night long and
one night this guy got in and he always
pulled the hottest chick and I was like
how does this guy do this and so he's
sitting in the back he's spitting into a
cup because he's dipping and this smoke
show next to him is like oh my God it's
so gross and then she passed me she's
like tell him how gross it is he said
hermosi life lesson and I like listened
up this girl is more attracted to the
fact that I don't care at all about what
she thinks then she is repulsed by the
fact that I'm dipping he was actually
giving me a really deep life lesson
which was that even though he understood
that some girls would probably think it
was gross he would feel more gross about
himself if he weren't who he really was
I realized there's two sides of it
either you pretend to be someone you're
not and the person actually falls for
somebody that you aren't or you're
exactly who you are and you can be
certain in that fact and if someone
doesn't like you [__] them then you can
actually have all the game you want
because the game is just you